hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about how the process of transcription
is different and prokaryotes versus
eukaryotes make sure that you understand
what the process of transcription and
dad is why it's important before you
proceed with this video specifically
transcription is the intermediate step
that connects DNA to proteins so it's
how genes are expressed in a Cell
genetic information is stored in DNA an
mRNA copy of the DNA is made that's the
transcript that's made in transcription
which we'll be talking about today and
then that gets translated into protein I
do have a video on the central dogma of
molecular biology that goes into more
detail on that process if you want to
watch that first and then come back to
this video but now let's get started
talking about transcription and how it
differs in prokaryotes versus eukaryotes
remember with prokaryotes we're talking
about mainly bacteria and with
eukaryotes we're talking about plants
animals fungi and algae protozoans
things like that so let's get started
prokaryotic mRNA that's what we are
referring to when I talk about the
transcript in most cases so prokaryotic
mRNA may be mono sister onok or
polycistronic while eukaryotic mRNA is
exclusively mono sister oneth now let's
talk about what those words mean
polycistronic is what we have happening
right here
so polycistronic is where you've got one
mRNA one mRNA transcript as the black
line here and multiple polypeptides and
multiple proteins are made from that one
transcript because there are multiple
genes per transcript so you can have
multiple genes represented on a
transcript and then multiple
polypeptides
from that polypeptides and proteins we
can use those worth interchangeably mono
says Stronach on the other hand is where
you've just got one gene per transcript
so that each transcript results in one
protein so again
prokaryotes can do this or this
eukaryotes are only mono so strongly
prokaryotes and eukaryotes also have
different types and numbers of
polymerase enzymes now here we're
talking about RNA polymerases remember
that DNA polymerases are enzymes that
replicate DNA during DNA replication so
they copy the DNA to make more DNA RNA
polymerase is use the DNA as a template
to make RNA and so RNA polymerase
enzymes are the main enzymes of this
transcription process so prokaryotes and
eukaryotes have different types and
numbers of polymerizes prokaryotes have
one polymerase RNA polymerase it only
works when it has a cofactor like
molecule that's called Sigma different
Sigma's can make the one RNA polymerase
transcribed in genes on the other hand
eukaryotes have three different
polymerizes known as RNA polymerase one
RNA polymerase 2 and RNA polymerase 3
and they also transcribe a different
subset of genes specifically genes for
mRNA which go on to be expressed as
proteins but then also genes for T RNAs
which carry amino acids to the ribosome
and translation and genes for our RNA
which is the RNA that helps make up
those ribosomes all of these different
types of RNA are being transcribed by
slightly different
Limor ANSYS in eukaryotes prokaryotes
and eukaryotes also have different
promoter elements now I'm not going to
go into a ton of detail on this but
basically there are promoter elements
usually that are upstream of a gene
meaning like before the gene starts
every once in a while downstream of the
gene meaning after it ends these
promoter elements are just elements that
are part of the nucleotide sequence and
the regions surrounding the gene that
are where the polymerase will bind or
where initiation factors will bind to
get transcription up and started and so
prokaryotes and eukaryotes have
different promoter elements they use
different sequences and different places
to carry out that function and they also
have different termination processes
so this is referring to the ending of
transcriptions
so basically when you've transcribed the
mRNA and you get to the end termination
has to happen and eukaryotes there are a
variety of termination factors that come
in to make sure that the RNA polymerase
lets go of the DNA and that the mRNA can
then go off and be translated in
prokaryotes there's a protein called Rho
R H o that often plays a role although
there are also Rho independent
termination processes where Rho does not
factor in but again they've just got
some prokaryotes and eukaryotes have
have some differences in their
termination procedures and in the
different kinds of proteins that play a
role in that eukaryotes also modify
their mRNA transcripts and three major
ways so when the transcription process
ends in eukaryotes we then have what's
known as pre mRNA and that's because for
it to become mature mRNA go through
something called post translate or
excuse me
post-transcriptional modifications so
modifications that happen once the
transcription has ended and so here are
these three ways one of them is the
addition of a five prime cap the five
prime cap has to be put on that helps to
target the mRNA out of the nucleus out
through a nuclear pore and helps the
ribosome basically find the mRNA so it
can dock on to it to proceed with
translation
there's also getting a three prime poly
a tail so this is when a whole bunch of
ad means that's the a so multiple ad
means poly a makes multiple ad means
multiple ad means are just tacked on to
the end of the
RNA and that's to protect the mRNA
because once it exits the nucleus
through a nuclear pore and goes out into
the cytoplasm to be translated there are
proteins out in the cytoplasm that will
actually degrade RNA they'll chew it up
and they eat it from the three prime end
and so since the three prime end has
this poly a tail on the end of it the
enzymes can chew up that poly a tail
without actually disrupting the
nucleotides of the actual mRNA sequence
that are coding for protein so it's a
protective mechanism there's also
something called splicing this is where
there are certain sequences of the pre
mRNA transcript known as intervening
sequences intervening sequences or
introns and these get spliced out they
get removed and then what's left are
these sequences that are going to be
expressed expressed sequences we call
these exons where the X comes from
Express and those get joins together and
as a sight note eukaryotes can also do
something that's called alternative
splicing which is basically where
different exons can be spliced in or out
so that you can have different
polypeptides that are distinct
structurally but related to each other
because they have some of the same exons
and they can come from the same gene
just depending on which exons are capped
in which ones are spliced out and so the
mRNA transcript goes through these three
processes before it then goes on to
translation on the other hand
prokaryotes they don't knew any of these
three things
instead they couple transcription and
translation that just means that
transcription and translation occur
simultaneously in other words
translation which is making poly
peptides from the mrna template that can
begin before transcription ends and
that's depicted here if there are DNA
and green our polymerase is right there
that's the RNA polymerase making the
mRNA shown in black we've got our
ribosomes in blue when there's multiple
ribosomes and a line like that it's
actually referred to as a poly ribosome
remember poly means many and each one of
them is making probably peptides and
those are shown here in pink and so what
you see here is that translation of the
mRNA has started before the RNA
polymerase has even done making the mRNA
so that's coupling and and prokaryotes
can do that of course because they don't
have a nucleus so with eukaryotes
transcription happens in the nucleus you
have these modifications happen then the
mature mRNA goes out into the cytoplasm
where then translation begins and
prokaryotes they don't have a nuclear
membrane and so the DNA and the
ribosomes can be near each other and so
you can have these two processes be
couples together if you're interested in
learning more about how prokaryotes
couple transcription and translation
I've got a separate video that goes into
more detail on that I also have a
separate video that goes into a lot more
detail on alternative splicing if you'd
like to learn a little bit more about
that one I also have a video on
comparing the process of DNA replication
in prokaryotes and eukaryotes so check
that one out too if you're interested
and thanks for watching biology
professor